michael walker on the hill for the race
to begin things
what you wonder about michael walker you
think that josh fleming is obviously
going to be a part of this game as the
bulk guy
how long do they go with michael walker
will it be one time through the order
two innings three innings we'll have to
wait and see on a 3-1
dj will flare one into center field
that's down for a hit so dj
stewart in his first half-bat as a
leadoff hitter in the bigs
waves to the dugout post single
whoa got him again up and in remember
trey was hitting the right elbow a few
weeks ago and mancini hit by a pitch
here
and i think it's the same elbow it
looked like it just you can feel this at
home
that didn't seem to hit him as hard as
the last one and mancini hopefully he'll
be able to
stick this one out here orioles have two
on nobody out
ground ball right side bronzo to walls
one
first base two and the rays turn a
very nice double play there there's a
little tap
two seven down the third window's gonna
make the play
we got to the bottom of the first no
score the aforementioned bruce zimmerman
been on a run
and uh you know more hits than innings
pitch don't see that very often not a
lot of walks
no home runs but mostly solos
that's a line drive base hit into left
hot shot lighter picked up by stuart
so margot off the fastball is aboard
he will hold here and down goes diaz
zimmerman to the breaking ball
he throws him the good slider for his
first strikeout 3-2
that is swung out and missed and
zimmerman strikes out a pair of rays
richard and freddie galvez galvez bunts
up the third base line picked up by
wendell thrown all the way across the
diamond on the run and it's in time for
the out paul did a raise make some plays
defensively how difficult was
that play mendel made that play
look routine that's a lot going on there
another chance for the orioles
with a runner at third base and two outs
and felika will see if he can give the
orioles the first run of this game
on a 2-2 valleca with a rope into left
field and the orioles are on the board
first
a rocket single from pat valenka to
bring in austin
hayes the youngsters love it and the
orioles lead in the second good to see
zimmerman
picking up a couple of quick outs now
deal with joey wendell
and another strike and another ground
ball to second base
a one two three second inning for bruce
zimmerman
he's retired six rays in a row so one
down here's dj stuart stewart reached on
a single leading off the ball game
three pitches there's a wave in a minute
three or fewer ball on the ground how
about three or fewer the ball never
touched the ground now santander the
switch hitter and he got it cutting the
miss
two strikeouts in the inning we go to
the race half of the third
with one out runners at the corner
johnny diaz come up
ground ball headed for the hole base hit
into left
wall scores margot is going to dig for
third and he's in there no play
and over at first through the rbi single
diaz
so still one out and still runners at
the corners
this pitch will be cold strike three on
the inside corner
2-2 a rosarena swings and it's eaten up
by galves who throws from his knees to
second base and galves is up an alert
today with that one
6-4 on the play but the rays get a run
to tie it up
fleming ready with a 3-2 pitch and a
swing and a miss he struck him out
of the chase looked like something off
speed it was a change up away
freddie galvez ground ball to short
walls right there and a strike to first
three up and three down
runners at first and second for the
raise to start the fourth
there's a chopper from wendell to first
and trey is going to have to race to the
base got the right foot in in time
here's taylor walls with the infield in
that's lined into left out base hit
lau scores mejia heads to the plate
no play there and the rays take a 3-1
lead on the bait set by walls how about
the adjustment made by taylor walls
got burned by the change up on pitch
number one
and then after the fastball up and in
orioles are going to go back down to
that changeup
two out bases empty six in a row for
josh fleming and here is
austin wins it in and out of the glove
of fleming
retrieves it the throw to first in time
to get the
baltimore catcher at first one two three
and there's one gun sending brasso to
the plate
that's a fastball hit to short galvez
circles this one and galvez throws out
brusso
here's a rosarena and this one is last
and
caught by the third baseman franco that
one was a bullet
but franco right in the path and
zimmerman
does get a one two three fifth inning
despite some hard contact
two out and nobody on the sixth it'll
leave it for anthony's son down here
liner into center and there's phillips
making the grab
little angle there as he came in to his
left
and reaching down made the catch and
here's the grab
by phillips then a slighter happy
afternoon for bruce on 2-2 here lau
rolls one over to mancini at first still
hanging around here on sunday afternoon
that's popped up and the orioles
should get out of it galvez against the
ceiling will make the play
mount castle leads off
sky to center not overly deep maybe
higher than deep
and phillips is there to make the catch
and it's a swing and miss hayes out of
there
look how long it's in the zone you got
to make a decision now look at look at
it starts to bottom out and it starts to
bottom out very quickly
two up two down freddie galvez
a little nubber left side moving to his
left wendell
throw to first in time a one two three
seventh inning for whistler
intentionally walked meadows to load the
bases
for randy rosarina he shoots it into
deep right center field
that ball is going to be out of here
or is it that ball is in play
i think cutter wendell statted first and
it's out of here
it is that ball was out of here
it appeared to be that way and then
there was a little delay but hunter
wendelstein
the first base umpire says that's gone a
grand slam for
and that's where it gets confusing you
know it did look like it it stayed
in play but it goes just over look at
this
just over front row up and back onto the
field of play
randy rosarina getting a little extra
work down there with the
push-ups after the grand slam it's a 7-1
lead for the raise and they're looking
for the final three outs
he takes care of stewart that fastball
on the outside corner 3-2
on the ground to third wendell
throws a strike to first
and a pop-up foul ball
mejia after it ray's win it raised
witness with 7-1
retiring the last 19 baltimore hitters
in succession
the rays sweep this series and go to 42
and 24.